[Music]
hey everyone welcome thank you for
coming
good to see we have nobody napping yet I
know it's an hour or so after lunch so
thanks so much for staying awake to get
you a little bit warmed up all right ask
you a quick show of hands how many of
you are familiar with Active Directory
alright great so in the right session
good to know it's pretty much out of the
room and for the three people who maybe
didn't raise their hands it's okay there
is many resources you can go check out
later the other question how many of you
have had some experience with Google
cloud platform getting a VM up creating
a network and doing some basic
infrastructure as a service okay so this
is probably about half the room and
pretty much everyone has experience with
AD that's great so you're in the right
session we're gonna be talking about how
you can extend your on-premises Active
Directory to Google cloud platform my
name is Siddharth PI I'm a product
manager with Google cloud I focus on
problems that work with identity and
security very excited to talk to you
today and even more excited to have with
me two very talented core presenters
either Ben Miller I'm a systems
administrator with Google I work on the
mergers and acquisitions infrastructure
services team hey you guys doing I'm
Kenny Hill I'm with Capital One Identity
and Access Management I focus on
directories in the cloud great so we'll
go ahead and get started so what I
thought I'd start off with is honesty
and apology I'm sorry we're not gonna
cover the heated issue of whether we
should call it on-premises or on-premise
or on-premise or on Prem we will take
that away to the evening hours but two
things in particular I'll leave you with
today one is as the show of hands showed
a lot of you do have Active Directory
deployed so we understand that and B is
leave you with some best practices and
guidance on how you can extend your
Active Directory investments you've
already made on to the Google cloud
platform so in particular the things we
will cover is how is it that you can use
your on-premises
directory where you do your users and
groups management to get Identity and
Access Management configured on GCP
we'll talk about some drivers and
architecture choices for actually
running ad on DCP itself after that we
have two great case studies coming up of
actual experiences of revving run ad on
DCP and we'll run it off with some best
practices so the first thing that we're
going to cover is how can you extend
your on-premises Active Directory users
and groups onto GCP for Identity and
Access Management there's probably the
question I get asked most often over the
last year or so because a lot of you
have put in that investment to start
working to have Active Directory all set
up your auditors are happy internal
security team the sign-off which is
great and I'm going to start getting
started with DCP so can you leverage
those existing investments and the
answer is yes and I'll show you how in
the next two slides what's coming up is
probably a fairly familiar topology to a
lot of you you probably have your users
and groups in your on-premises Active
Directory they are sitting in your
Active Directory domain controllers and
then for a variety of reasons several
customers have either a DFS or paying or
octa or any of these other Federation
products deployed so you can take those
on-premises users and get single sign-on
to variety of other relying parties or
applications and so the question is when
the application is Google cloud platform
itself how is it that you can connect
the two so a canonical use case that
comes up as we often find that is
customers maybe somebody gets interested
with bigquery and wants to go ahead and
set things up so that a certain group of
users can go ahead and do things with
bigquery so the way that you do it in
GCP is via rule-based authorization so
if you were a bigquery admin you could
then go ahead and essentially do a
variety of things with the query so how
do you set it up I have the slide coming
up a little soak it in for a second it's
Google cloud identity
there's a lot of things on this slide
and it's a full identity as a service
product I won't be going too deep into
it today but I did want you to know it
has identity it has policies a very
strong support for device management but
there's two features in particular which
is all we need for the question we set
it out to answer and those two features
are a it allows you to sync your users
and groups from on-premises Active
Directory onto a Google cloud identity
domain B you can set up your Google
Cloud identity domain to indicate that
you'd like the authentication of those
users to happen with your on-premises
Federation endpoint and by going and
using these two features you can have
your users and groups from on-premises
Active Directory be used for bigquery or
any other I am and GCP so let's go ahead
and take a look at that in this demo
okay so as my screen comes up what
you're looking at should seem pretty
familiar to a lot of you since your
experience with Active Directory this is
the active directory administrative
center now further ok purpose of the
demo I need to go ahead and re-establish
my RDP as it comes up what you'll see is
I have a active directory administrative
center open in the on-premises
environment
great so this should look familiar it is
your on-premises Active Directory I have
created an who you in here for GCP which
is currently blank they'll go ahead and
run a simple PowerShell script and with
the script has done is it's gone ahead
and pre created for you some users and
groups so as i refresh have three users
in my on-premises active directory Alice
Bob and Charlie and I have a group GCP
security admins which has Alice and Bob
as its members so this what we have
setup in an on-premises ad probably
simulates a lot of deployments you have
today I now go ahead and switch on to a
VM they better have Google Cloud
directory sync setup so what this is
doing is it'll go ahead and take the
users from that or you and groups and
sync it up to a Google Cloud identity
domain so one thing I should call out is
a lot of you if you've been using GCP G
suite in particular for a while you may
be familiar of a term Google domain
which is the same thing as a Google
Cloud identity domain so I'll go ahead
and sing these up what this is doing is
it's now pushing those users and groups
into Google so I'll switch my screens
and what you are now looking at is the
admin console for Google Cloud identity
so they refresh my screen the three
users we just created Alice Bob and
Charlie are now available in the Google
Cloud identity domain and as I go to the
groups you are you'll see the group GCP
security admin is also available here so
I'll go ahead and take this group and
it's now all come up from your
on-premises ad into GCP so what next now
let's go back to the thing we were
trying to do to do that I'll apply this
group you're now looking at the IM page
of a GCP project and i'll go ahead and
add a role i'll give the users of this
particular group which we just synced in
from your on-premises ad the role of
bigquery admin and so as I go ahead and
hit save you now see that this group has
bigquery admin I am on this project now
the interesting thing here as we come
back to our slides is effectively that
you
have this set of groups these set of
users who can be added in or out of your
on-premises ad group and have the access
changes reflected back on G CPI M
without needing to go ahead and do
anything special into this I M page so
as we come back to our slides please
what you will notice is we will have two
additional items coming up on to this I
am policy that I just showed you pretty
soon one is you will be able to say that
allow these users to only have access
for a specific time window so the one at
the top is the policy which is set up
but down below is a special expression
that will allow you to essentially have
your group sink ahead of time and say
only for that hour R or only for that
month are those users allowed to have
access and second is you'll be able to
further restricted based on the source
IPS that they're actually connecting
from so that's the first part of the
session where we saw how you can use
your on-premises ad extended onto GCP
and use that for I am and this where we
come to an interesting transition and
it's a slightly tricky point to make so
I need your help everything we looked at
so far was having your on-premises ad
extended onto GCP without requiring VPN
by syncing your users and groups into
your GCP domain what we now go and take
a look at is if you are trying to run
Active Directory or a be related apps on
GCP how do you go ahead and do that and
for this we do not need cloud identity
or a VPN to be set up for the things we
are going to talk about next so that's
some pain so a lot of times when you
need Active Directory in the cloud is if
you are thinking of a migration project
so go ahead and soak in that visual for
a second and I'll talk through it
so what you're seeing is you have an
application that's talking to your
on-premises Active Directory over a set
of Active Directory protocols now what
are the cases when you may need Active
Directory as you think of moving this
app or the server onto GCP so one very
common use cases if you have gone ahead
and domain join these applications onto
Google cloud platform onto Active
Directory and you want to run them on
Google cloud platform so in that case
were looking for ad in other cases if
the app does LDAP or Kerberos or Windows
integrated off it's looking for a domain
controller the next set of things is if
the app has logic for retrieving things
that are stored in Active Directory
itself most often it's group based
membership when the application houses
the authorization logic in itself
another time as if you had used a ad
client-side library for instance you had
a dotnet based app and if that was
making any calls over to systems or
directory services it would look to find
a domain controller and the last bit is
when you do go ahead and have your
application migrated to the cloud you
have a choice to make
which is do you still want your
on-premise network to be on the critical
path for each application authentication
lookup or would you rather have it scale
in cloud have low latency and have the
cloud application be independently and
highly available how is it that these
choices end up manifesting your
architecture options let's take a look
first thing you can do in any of these
cases is the simplest just go ahead and
set up your VPN or a cloud interconnect
and have your Active Directory continue
to recite on-premises and so this way
it's pretty quick to configure but you
have higher latency for all your
applications every single request is
going back to your on-premises network
so what do you do second option you have
is you can go ahead and choose to deploy
read only domain controllers on to
Google Cloud now the advantage in this
case is it's a read-only replica of
Active Directory but those of you who
have worked with it for a while will
probably know that there are certain
operations that are still being chained
or refer back to your full domain
controllers which in this case would
reside on premises so your app still
going back to your on-premises network
for getting those done in terms of A+
this does not bring in everybody's
credentials onto
any cloud deployment so you can have no
users passwords in the cloud by default
some of you may like that from a
security perspective however and it also
lets you only have replicated in a
certain set of users passwords into that
cloud ad deployment on the other hand
the biggest challenge with our OD ceases
there is application compatibility
things you should think about so if you
go in Google for our ODC application
compatibility the first link gives you a
list of apps that support our OD cease
or not so that's something to factor in
the next option is to go ahead and
deploy your writable or regular domain
controllers into cloud and in this case
you obviously have your Active Directory
data available entirely on DCP it's low
latency because your application is then
going for all operations so the ad DC
just deployed there however the thing to
keep in mind in both this as well as a
previous configures if you have multiple
Active Directory domains you may end up
needing to deploy domain controllers for
each of those domains into cloud so if
you had a merger and acquisition use
case or for any other reasons at 3 or 4
ad domains require multiple domain
controllers from each of those domains
so to get around that another thing you
can do is set up a new Active Directory
domain on Google cloud platform use the
Active Directory trust relationship
model to establish a trust with your
on-premise ad and this does work well
because you effectively are able to have
three or four different ad domains where
our users are having their credentials
stored and authentication happening
however all your resources and
applications which are running in the
cloud can join or just work against the
Active Directory domain which is now
hosted fully within cloud another thing
you could think about when you think of
moving to the cloud and having a hybrid
deployment is to consider having a
disaster recovery site on Google cloud
platform and so what the numbers you're
seeing on the right effectively show an
example of AD site replication cost
which you could utilize to go ahead and
have things set up so that your users
and applications on-premises are usually
not reaching back to the cloud and only
in the event of a failover will they
come in and use the cloud DC's so these
are five options you have in terms of
architecture and by this point you're
probably wondering
which of these make sense for your
specific use case now to help answer
that I'm really excited to share with
you the highlight of our segment today
which is the Benin Kenny experience
they'll come up and share with you what
is it that work for them as they look to
have a be running on GCP hey guys first
I want to thank Sid and want to thank
Ben for allowing me to come up here and
share a little bit about Capital One's
Google Cloud Active Directory journey
hopefully there's time at the end for
questions if not feel free to connect
always really excited to hear what
others are doing in the identity and
directory space in the cloud see the
question up on the board or screen why
extend Active Directory to Google cloud
there are many reasons the main driver
for us is resiliency and speed
let me explain a little bit of what that
means and some of the design inputs that
went into some of our decisions
deforming areas we focused on with our
demand controller design first one
security I'm gonna gloss over that and
skip it not enough time for me to really
dive deep Ben is gonna share some
security practices next area for us is
directory size since going on on the
cloud we've had exponential growth in
our directories running at a 38 and 60
gigabit and TDS did have about 2.5
million objects in each directory
between 100 150,000 use both users and
group objects understanding directory
size there's many reasons for our growth
one of the main ones that I'm excited
about is the development we've had on
cloud platform of applications requiring
role based access we've also kind of
taken the concept of tags from cloud and
we're writing more data
to our directory this is this allows us
to correlate Active Directory objects
with cloud things utilize it in our
provisioning system next area is
resiliency the Nexus speed has I was
doing the slides for this I realized
same inputs really went into both of
them to ensure Active Directory
authentication and authorization is
always available doesn't matter if it's
a federated sam'l syndication a windows
authentication LDAP application bind a
database authentication directory needs
to be there same holds true when your
domain joining infrastructure and it
wants to scale so the directory needs to
be there so for us going down
interconnect or VPN that wasn't really
an option as we want to no matter the
situation ensure that we can scale
applications to create a seamless
experience for applications when
switching projects and regions a
developer application team devops team
no matter what you call them they should
not need to know anything about ad sites
maintain different URL mappings we even
have application teams that they don't
even know it's Active Directory on the
backend when they need help they ask
where is the LDAP team to provide the
fastest domain join Directory
replication and now the app experience
possible key way to be successful in
this bullet is to keeping your traffic
on Google Cloud I'm not going to give
exact time test metrics you guys I
highly recommend testing this yourself
in a world where every millisecond
counts is important to ensure that
traffic stays on the most optimal path
and this is probably one of the biggest
reasons we build domain controllers on
compute engine to quickly rehydrate and
be able to increase ad capacity at
Capital One we rebuild all
infrastructure every 45 to 60 days
maximum domain controllers are no
exception to that rule they get rebuilt
we call this rehydrate so we are
constantly rebuilding our domain
controllers that's why directory saw
directory sizes up there need to
understand your build times it's
important to know exactly how long it's
going to take to build domain
controllers even if using the install
for media file which you backup the date
you back up baby database just this fall
you import it if you have quite a few
objects the domain promote process is
still going to do like a checksum I
don't know the correct term for it but
of every object and that's where the lag
is gonna happen so understanding your
directory size and the speed that you
can build domain controllers is going to
help you determine is your directory
small enough are you able to Auto scale
if so I'm jealous or are you gonna have
to run it monitor a little bit over your
monitoring high peaks meaning you're
running a little bit over capacity at
all times or do you keep a reserve pool
of live domain controllers running on
smaller instances in a reserved ad site
and utilize scaling technology to kind
of bring them in and out as you need
them next I'm going to show you a few of
the high-level design decisions in a
typical traditional ad site topology for
on premise you usually have a single ad
site or two per data center each of
these ad sites is usually gonna have
some sort of single point of failure if
it's power network shared storage or
other
this doctor in our Google cloud model we
utilize we put them in controllers in
every zone available in each region we
deploy this is essentially treating the
whole region as a single ad site this
provides a more resilient topology in
the on-premise model you it's hard to
test if you you can you manage your
sites and services and your cost and for
the next closest site and there can be
errors in it you can shut down Network
to a data center and you can set and you
can know that everything's
authenticating and authorizations
occurring but do you know exactly where
all that's going in this model and cloud
you know it's just staying in the same
site this also ensures that any
applications that utilize DC locator
process are going to pick domain
controller in the ad site in region
staying on Google Cloud as their primary
for applications that cannot utilize DC
locator who utilize an LDAP load
balancer our configuration for load
balancer LDAP secure 6:36 GCS global
catalog secure three to six nine coming
into the load balancer this ensures that
all traffic outside of the project is
secure we then terminate at the load
balancer to regular 389 three to six
eight and point at domain controllers
across multiple zones
realize global catalog secure port for
applications which chase referrals many
Java based applications chase referrals
and sometimes you have cots products
deployed which you cannot disable in the
if you're not familiar with chase
referrals it's when you point an
application to a domain controller and
instead of utilizing that domain
controller it pulls back all the a
records and randomized very randomizes
I'm per the client and then just picks a
random one if utilize global catalog
port it disables referral chasing we're
predominantly a Linux app which does not
have DC locator process by - by default
without third-party products there are
also many applications which are not a
b-side aware that cannot utilize the
load balancer or even some of the
horrible applications that you have to
point directly to a domain controller an
example of one of those applications
you'd point directly out that domain
controller is a something that needs to
read and write almost simultaneously
like your identity and lifecycle
management application or a provisioning
application where if it doesn't read and
write at the same one you could have
collisions d we utilize a root DSE query
so LDAP s root DSE query to load bounce
or returning the DNS hostname the
applications can utilize this they can
put it in a script or a job ensure their
configuration is always pointing at a
live domain controller even if we're
rebuilding or rehydrating our domain
controllers if they have this job set up
they'll know they always have a live
domain controller as I mentioned it
isn't extremely important to ensure we
are replicating Active Directory data as
fast as possible in this model if we
were to fail to another region
applications need to be able to read the
same data that
read in one region in another one also
allows us to more effectively get to a
just-in-time access model and enhance
our privileged access password rotation
the legacy replication strategy was
designed more than 18 years ago when
network was slow and also very expensive
we choose to utilize a full mass
replication with change notification
strategy change notification treats
replication on the site linked same as
it would enter site Oh diagram I'm
showing up there we are replicating from
site to site on premise to all of our
Google regions and then we do as fast as
we can replication between the sites to
close out a couple more lessons that
we've learned along the way limit your
use of Group Policy objects there are
many more cloud friendly configuration
management solutions out there Ben's
gonna actually show you one that's
available for free that works you can
also utilize you can also harden your
image build stack all your configuration
settings in your image and that's
another approach managing group policy
deviations and exceptions in a cloud
model is not operational
the efficient for the directory support
teams or the application teams the
application teams are going to need to
script moving the objects or adding to a
security filter group which means they
need a credit any credentials which
means they have to also have secured a
password so we don't take that approach
we only deployed GPO for high level
settings which there's no way we're
going to reverse monitor and log
everything even if you're not going to
utilize the day
immediately you will want it later there
are many other services besides compute
engine which can enhance directory
services in the cloud so you will want
this historical data when you're
building out tools and applications on
cloud on Google platform automate your
domain controller buildin I already
mentioned this one it's worth repeating
ensure your build process for domain
controllers is efficient and you're able
to quickly add capacity domain
controllers are in a different category
of course services than regular
applications the domain controllers need
to be there before the applications need
to consume it another thing is is a be
of you who are very familiar it's
extremely chatty wait until you put it
in the cloud when teams are auto-scaling
they're spinning up thousand instances
at a time pulling them down
ATS going to be chatty ER so being able
to add capacity really quick is
important last thing I'll leave you with
at Capital One
we do not troubleshoot isolated in
domain controller issues in the cloud we
will give it one we reboot if that issue
persists domain controller comes out we
bring another one in thank you guys for
sitting listening to me
thank you said
that was actually a very very
interesting set of you know experiences
you heard Capital One talk about how
they're running Active Directory in
production on GCP with a fairly large
size that the two angles in particular
that stood out for me was one is even
when you're looking to run something
like Active Directory which is a very
core Windows Server workload trying to
do LDAP by leveraging cloud DNS and
cloud load balancing was interesting to
see how they designed the LDAP load
balancer that's definitely something
things like this is you heard an explore
of moving to the cloud are interesting
ideas to try to try the second was the
message that we were left with which is
you should go ahead and look to automate
your domain controller creation the
domain controller build process and
that's actually a great point and I'm
excited to call upon Ben who's gonna
come in and share with us more about
what is it that alphabet does when it
also deploys domain controllers in
production and how is it that you have
automated DC Bell welcome Ben hi as I
mentioned a bit ago I work on Google's
M&A infrastructure services team I work
with a group of talented systems
administrators in Colorado and
California that built and operate the
project that I'm going to be talking
about today one of the things that our
team does is to build and maintain core
IT infrastructure for an array of
acquisitions and partnerships to make
this happen we rely heavily on code and
automation our project gecko is code
driven managed IT infrastructure for
alphabet entities and acquisitions
deployed in Google Cloud the problem
that we set out to solve was consistent
management of many unrelated Active
Directory domains rather than a single
large forest as Kenny was describing
with a fairly small team we managed
services like Active Directory DNS DHCP
NPS and radius for many small to medium
sized environments in order to
accomplish this we put tremendous focus
on using the DevOps approach of
infrastructure as code using code and
automation to deploy and maintain these
environments and minimizing manual
changes so I'd like to share some of the
keen design goals that informed the
design of gecko and I'd propose that
these are goals that most of you would
share if you're bill
hangout domain infrastructure and Google
cloud I'll give you some examples of how
we got to where we are but just
understand there are many other ways to
achieve the same goals so let me break
each one of these down first it's
important to limit access to the GCP
projects to contain your domain
infrastructure protecting your domain
controllers from malicious or accidental
action is critical to the security of
these environments so we build domain
infrastructure and isolated GCP projects
having ownership or instance admin roles
in GCE means having tremendous power
over the instances that run in those
projects for example depending on your
iam roles in the project you can create
or delete instances you can access their
logs create new Windows accounts and
change passwords on those machines so we
use role accounts and custom iam grants
to give just the access needed to
resources in our projects we only allow
folks that are domain admins in the
environment to become instance admins in
the projects that they run in we
carefully consider the consequences of
granting even lesser access to compute
resources and the projects that contain
these domain controllers approach every
cloud I am grant by asking yourself can
you can someone use this access to
escalate their privileges in the domain
will this grant let someone modify
instances metadata or access sensitive
logs so ok now we built our domain
controllers in an isolated project
fantastic they're running perfectly
smoothly nothing's going wrong they're
under glass and nobody can talk to them
so what do we do next
first we use instance tags to define VPC
firewall rules that control they'll
control the flow of network traffic
within our project this ensures that we
know where all of our traffic is coming
from and where it is going to once these
rules are in place we can establish
network connections to our customers
cloud and on-premise we one hour an
infrastructure to be available and
performant so we do a couple of things
we co-locate our instances in the same
GCP zones that our customer projects run
in and then we use cloud VPC peering to
create fast
or connections between the virtual
private cloud networks of these projects
finally we interact with on Prem
networks via cloud VPN again placing our
compute instances in cloud regions that
are close to those networks our next
design goal was to automate provisioning
and to implement source controlled
configuration management infrastructure
is code is is key to scaling IT as a
service but we're not just concerned
with shaving down provisioning time by
centralizing our code and config in
source repositories we can force all
changes to go through peer review and a
suite of tests with sufficient proof
provisioning and configuration
automation you might choose to build new
instances rather than applying updates
to existing ones as Kenny described
you can bring new instances online and
ensure they are operating correctly
before bringing your existing capacity
offline and with gecko our instance
provisioning automation is built around
getting our configuration management in
place as early and as possible and
making sure that it stays in control so
we automate deployment of new domain
controllers and other instance types
using a couple of stages so for the
first stage of our instance build we
take advantage of the suspect stage of
Windows installation to inject our build
artifacts onto the machine this is
possible thanks to the GCE agent that
runs in the stock GCE image that we
build our instances from it will look
for a script configured in the project
or instance metadata and then it will
run that script all we're doing in this
initial stage is to download build
artifacts from a canonical source so
here I've highlighted a very short
PowerShell script where I'm storing that
I'm storing as a value in a hash table
and when I pass the hash table to the
command look below the key value pairs
in the hash table become instance
metadata so when I provision the machine
the GCE agent will go looking for the
specialized script in metadata and upon
finding it it will execute it as I said
all this particular script is is doing
is copying instance build artifacts from
GCS now I could instead be using a git
repository or I could be using a package
repository or something else the
important thing is that all of the build
artifacts that I'm using are coming from
a vetted
source everything I'm using to build
this instance should be centrally stored
everything that I'm using to build this
instance should be peer-reviewed or
should be built by something that was
itself peer-reviewed after the sysprep
specialized stage completes in the
instance reboots our second stage script
is triggered this script will install
configuration management prerequisites
initialize the configuration management
system and then Shepherd it through its
first run of config management to make
sure that it completes successfully for
our domain controllers we use PowerShell
desired state configuration as our
configuration management system so here
I've given you an example of the DSC
configuration required to create a
brand-new domain controller on a Windows
Server core machine that's really about
it the windows feature DSC resource
ensures that the ad domain services
feature is installed and the X ad domain
resource handles the creation of the
domain in a production environment
you're going to see a lot of additional
code and configuration to handle things
like credential management and testing
and other things that are specific to
your environment but this really is all
there is to creating a new domain using
PowerShell DSC speaking of credential
management the final thing I wanted to
touch on was protecting your secrets
building domain infrastructure
necessitates handling some very
important credentials including those
needed to create a new domain controller
or our new domain entirely everyone at
some point is going to be tempted to put
a password in the script we've all been
around the block don't do it don't use
plain text don't just use obfuscation
rot13 is not encryption really encrypt
your secrets store them in a place where
you will have an audit trail every time
they are accessed have sufficient
logging in place to know when those
credentials are used anywhere in your
environment so there are a lot of ways
to protect your credentials but I wanted
to show you a pretty simple example
that's enabled by cloud key management
service or cloud kms cloud kms allows
you to encrypt and decrypt secrets based
on cloud iam access grants so I can have
one set of accounts that has permissions
just to encrypt secrets and then I can
have another set of accounts that just
has permission to decrypt secrets here
I'm using a very simple g-cloud command
to encrypt a plaintext string
and store the results in a file then I'm
uploading that file to Google Cloud
Storage and when I need to use this very
secure password to join my domain
controller to my domain the code can
retrieve the encrypted file from GCS
decrypt the secret and inject it into my
configuration management without the
plaintext password ever landing on disk
now we could if you imagine just take
things a step further and build a
process where no human ever has to know
what certain passwords are so you can
imagine having a process to generate a
new random password as part of an
automated provisioning process so let's
say that I have a password for a break
glass administrative account the right
service account in the right place will
be able to access the secret in order to
set the password for the break glass
account but no human will ever have to
know what this is
if on-call uses cloud KMS to decrypt the
secret I'll know about it
thanks to my audit logs and the same
process can be triggered again to
automatically rotate the password so in
summary when building domain
infrastructure and GCP you should
carefully consider these aspects of your
design limiting access to just word is
needed and isolating your domain
infrastructure automating your
provisioning and deployment and using
configuration management and protecting
your critical secrets thank you very
much I'll hand the rest of the time back
to Sid Thank You Ben so much for joining
us the two key takeaways I think from
this segment for me where one is like
sort of an operational step-by-step of
how can you actually automate BC build
using tooling which is hopefully
familiar to a lot of you have been
working with IDI for a while second was
you saw Ben talk about what's a good way
to go ahead and protect secrets in the
cloud in this case for the Active
Directory use case but using cloud kms
and GCS during the encrypted secret it's
something you can extend for other
applications you do with GC p2 as we go
into the sort of final section of the
talk I wanted to go ahead and touch upon
and bring together some of these best
practices to solve it 50 not a complete
list you've heard some very great pearls
of wisdom from both Ben and Kenny but
thought I'd leave you with a few things
to keep in mind as you start thinking
about running Active Directory or
extending it to Google Cloud
the first set of things is around Active
Directory design so one of the things
you should think about as you move to
cloud is there is no reason to not be
high available so for domain controllers
always have at least 2 DC's one in each
zone second when you think about your
Active Directory site topology you have
two options one is you can pick a simple
option which is you create a single
Active Directory site for all of GCP and
using the power of our multi regional
VPC effectively able to have that work
well it's a quick way to get started
second you heard Kenny described
especially as you move towards more
performant applications to have one site
per region and what this will do is for
any of the applications or servers you
have running in that region they will
always go to the fat closest domain
controller and still see low latencies
in terms of connectivity back to
on-premises there's networking options
cloud VPN cloud interconnect you're
welcome to go study those more and see
which one works well for you that's
because a lot of Active Directory
operations require non internet like
private network line-of-sight
connectivity between domain controllers
as many of you are probably aware the
last part is for any applications or
servers you choose to move to GCP and
you do have one or more ad sites on DCP
placing them in the same Active
Directory site will lead to the right
type of things happening which should
keep your DNS and AD operations working
well finding the closest TC from a
operations and security angle a few
things to keep in mind one is there's
obviously a plethora of choices when you
come to cloud for running compute you
ever see one to make just like you would
if you were purchasing hardware to run
your domain controllers make the right
type of choices preemptable VMs may be
cool but probably not a good idea
fronting ad domain controllers you wanna
think about static IPs and things like
that in terms of G cpi-m permissions you
saw that being something we covered in
the last two case studies but I did want
to hone in the point here's something to
keep in mind if you have a domain
controller running in a VM on compute
anybody who has compute instance admin
on that DCP project can go right click
reset windows password
and effectively elevate themselves to a
domain admin now just like you wouldn't
very loosely put your Active Directory
on-premises domain controllers in
physical environments you didn't fully
trust when it comes to managing it in
the cloud especially in DCP you want to
be mindful of which type of I am
permissions you have on those projects
in particular anybody with set I am
policy is able to set iron permissions
on that GCP project and give themselves
or other variety of I am roles so it's
generally a good hygiene to keep in mind
but especially when you're running
domain controllers be mindful of that
second we have a resource hierarchy
within GCP which is beyond the scope of
this talk today but to give you an idea
you can have projects which are inside
of folders which are inside of
organizations and so there is an
inheritance model of iron permissions
there too so I see several of you
nodding I won't go into more detail but
something to study and keep in mind as
you're thinking of running ad lastly if
you wish to have more isolation for ad
you can always set up a bastion active
directory project it is more things that
you'd have to configure but did won't
you don't that is an option for
high-security cases you can then still
use VPC peering and shared VP C's to
have all your domain controllers in that
project but have your servers and
applications and other projects that can
still reach those domain controllers
lastly there is a session later this
week I have a link in a couple of slides
which will talk about how you can use
hardened security on Google cloud
platform for all of your sensitive or
closed including ad so I encourage you
to find out more about that and look to
leverage that so fall of this is
sounding interesting to you and you
wanna get started I wanted to do leave
you with just a few quick slides of
examples of things you can do one is we
have a Google cloud solution that talks
you through step by step how you can get
your highly available Active Directory
domain up on GCP and have a slide with
all the links in a minute if you want to
take a photo of that second this you can
also choose to extend an existing ad
domain onto GCP so there's a whitepaper
phase 3 of the swipe paper talks about
Active Directory considerations there is
a click to deploy if you wanted to go
ahead and just get a any domain spun up
and start playing with an experimenting
with that we have that something you can
go ahead and love
and a lot of what you've heard today is
focused around two themes one is having
high available multi-regional Active
Directory on GCP and B has been around
specifically automating domain
controller creation and so for that I'm
actually excited to share with you what
I Toby has done so I do peer I topia
excuse me as a partner who we've been
working with for the last several months
they have a very interesting set of
things they're announcing right now at
next in particular the ability to extend
an existing Active Directory domain and
the ability to have multiple sites one
site per region similar to how you heard
Kenny advice and talk about how they're
doing it in Capital One they have a boot
down below if you want to go and get
automated support for everything that
you've heard about today encourage you
to go check them out so here are some
links if you wanted to go back and play
with that one order thank you all for
coming and please let us know if there's
more we can do in GCP to help support
these use cases thank you so much
you
[Music]